derrière ses grilles ils étaient une
vingtaine de jardiniers amateurs à
profiter du beau temps
ce dimanche 28 février aux jardins
familiaux de guyancourt en cette fin
d'hiver la préparation du terrain est
importante
ce guillon courtois entretient sa part
fait depuis 18 ans ce jour là il est en
train de pêcher la terre c'est pour
nettoyer le terrain comme ça après
quentin centrale moment venu on passera
un goût de motoculteurs et puis on
pourra cultiver
il ya une petite fenêtre là on se dit où
là on va au moins nettoyer on va au
moins se préparer puisque c'est pas
vraiment la période où on peut tout
planter les jardins familiaux sont
ouverts tous les jours
gérard retraité via environ deux heures
trente par jour
il fait tout lui-même on peut appeler ça
du bio a fait vraiment du bio qu'on fait
là moi je n'ai pas de produits chimiques
quand il ya des mauvaises herbes hd
arrache moi même nom - un peu d'engrais
un peu de jeu d'abord j'ai mis du fumier
de cheval
les proches de m du terreau je mettrai
fraises pour obtenir une parcelle il
faut attendre plusieurs années les 91
sont déjà toute occupée un terrain vous
coûtera 125 euros à l'année mais si vous
voulez en acquérir un pas besoin
forcément d'avoir la main verte
il n'y a pas d'objectifs de production
en tant qu'hôtel ce qu'on demande aux
jardiniers c'est véritablement d'avoir
l'envi de mettre en valeur la parcelle
pour pouvoir planter et récolter le
fruit de votre travail
il faudra attendre encore le printemps